- Dans- Dansn pays e un pays epe
à uà u violentne violentdeuxièee
de la de la ndémie, pandémie, ss
régionrégionx et lesaux et lesas
politipolities contiques contiet
comme comme  de riensi de rien'.
Le preLe preer minismier minise,
NarendNarend Modi, pra Modi, pêe
devantdevantes foule des foulecs
de milde milers de pliers de pt.
Le ré Le réisateuralisateur
primé primé ternatiointernatiol,
AnuragAnuragashyap e Kashyap e,,
depuisdepuisongtemps longtempsue
opposaopposa au gouvnt au gouvn.
Comme Comme nt d'auttant d'auts,
il a sil a si la cenubi la cenre
grandigrandiante depssante depse
au pouau pouir du prvoir du prie
nationnationiste hinaliste hinu.
Cette Cettecène scènee trois  s
du fildu fil"Manmaarm "Manmaaryi
il y ail y arois ans trois ansae
sans lsans lccord du'accord dué.
La raiLa rain : on vson : on vtt
un perun pernnage sisonnage si .
"Des  "Des ns prochgens proch r
attaquattaqut, sur lent, sur l x
sociausociau ma fillx, ma fillet
les meles meres de mmbres de mf.
Je visJe visonstamme constamment
sous psous pssion," ression," t.
Le fo Le foateur d'ndateur d' s
médiasmédiasndépenda indépendass
expliqexpliq que lesue que lesos
et leset lesédias d' médias d'ft
harcelharcel par le és par le u,
mêmê pour deme pour dechoses bss
comme comme s gazouides gazouii.
Le si Le si "The Wite "The Wi"u
quotidquotidn le conien le conie
depuisdepuisovembre  novembre rr
et criet crique la gtique la gtn
gouvergouvermentale nementale  .
Cette Cette uverturecouverture u
au fonau fonteur et dateur et  e
journajournaste d'êliste d'êtres
pour dpour dséminatiisséminati s
et incet incation àitation à la.
Ce jo Ce jonaliste urnaliste ee
et sa et sa tite équpetite équee
tiennetienne un regint un regire
de toude tous les prtes les prss
sur lesur lejournalis journalie.
Il préIl prése que lcise que l s
de prede pree critiqsse critiqss
du goudu gournement vernement rt
l'accl'accs au pès au pncipal a,
soit lsoit lgouvernee gouvernen.
À l À lnverse, 'inverse, ux qut
des redes rertages fportages fts
pour lpour lgouvernee gouvernent
un accun accs privès privégié a.
Le mo Le mo dernieris dernier,
trois trois ganismesorganismesns
basés basés  Suèen Suè, en Angde
et auxet auÉtats-U États-Us onté
l'Indel'Indeu rang d au rang due
électoélectole. Le prale. Le pst
autrefautrefs la pluois la pluve
démocrdémocrie du moatie du moe.
Il estIl estaintenan maintenanci
les Eles Etats juÉtats jug partt
libreslibrescomme la, comme lao,
laonla Honie et lagrie et laurq.
Selon Selones rappo les rapposs
de Varde Varties of ieties of m,
FreedoFreedoHouse etm House etne
Unit, Unit, s opposales opposasu
gouvergouverment sonnement sonqs
d'enned'ennes de la mis de la t,
et leset lesontre-po contre-pooe
les méles méas et ledias et leu,
ont vuont vueur indé leur indéne
attaquattaqu et érodée et érod..
"Ils  "Ils sent essdisent esstt
que l'que l'de est uInde est u ,
soutiesoutie mêment même'arriè -
petit-petit-ls du pfils du pre e
la natla natn, le Maion, le Mat.
Il ajoIl ajoe que leute que leot
Modi sModi sst servi'est serviut
agricoagrico et de lle et de lpe
po rpour rtreindreestreindreavae
les liles lirtés.bertés.
Les p Les pteformeslateformesen
sont lsont l plus rées plus réns
de ce de ce sserremeresserreme.s
décrétdécréts à lées à lfin févr
permetpermetnt au mitent au mise
de l'Ide l'Iormationnformationer
ou mêou même de come de coer de.
Le gouLe gournement vernement dà
tout ptout pr promouour promouie
fondamfondamtaliste entaliste n.
Il ferIl fert mêait mê pressiomr
les Amles Amon, Netfazon, Netfxs
platefplatefmes pourormes pourut
de colde colborer avlaborer av s
réalisréaliseurs indateurs indi.
ConséqConséqnces : auences : aoe
et isoet isoment poulement poucx
qui osqui ost s'exprent s'expre.
Malgré  Malgré s pressiles pres
et l'iet l'ilement, solement,  d
demeurdemeur en Indeer en Indeor
son arson aret sa cot et sa coen
du goudu gournement vernement d.
Les prLes prhaines aochaines aét
foi defoi deout, d'a tout, d'aln
l'éditl'éditr du siteur du sit".
Il ve Il ve croire ut croire es
fera lfera lchoix dee choix deat
que leque leIndiens s Indiens ur
sans csans ctrainte ontrainte  e
confiaconfiae aux prnce aux prhs
électiélectis généraons généras,
prévueprévuedans tros dans tro .
Ici P Ici Plippe Lehilippe Lea,
Radio Radioanada, D-Canada, Dh.